Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: No using SCP-159 to
make your office impenetrable!
SCP-159 is a seemingly ordinary neon sign
reading "Open."
When the sign is displayed in the window of
a location, the moment it is unplugged from
an electrical source it renders the building
or room impossible to enter, or destroy, using
anything from hurricane-level winds to X-rays.
Dr. Bright is not allowed to borrow this sign
for his office, no matter how much he promises
to keep it plugged in.
He does not want it for aesthetic purposes,
or, as he says, to let his colleagues know
they are always welcome.
He is, in fact, planning to unplug it and
cackle wildly as anyone tries to open the
door, while yelling "You can't get me!!!"
We're not falling for that one again.